au 18e jour de ce conflit mote nicolas
yves au sud du pays la dernière grande
ville sur la route des russes avant
d'atteindre odessa cible de nombreux
bombardements depuis plusieurs jours le
point sur la situation avec gwendoline
de bono notre envoyé spécial avos nissan
sq je me trouve dans la ville de bosnie
sienne ce qui est située environ à 80 km
au nord de nicolas yves sur le même axe
alors bosnie sienne ce que c'est une
ville qui a la foi se prépare à une
attaque russe mais qu'il a déjà vécu en
effet le 1er mars et bien les troupes
russes sont entrés dans la ville un par
l'une des routes principales qui est
derrière moi lorsqu'ils ont vu les
premiers tanks et bien les soldats de
l'armée ukrainienne ont fait sauter ce
pont pour protéger les accès à la ville
alors nous nous sommes rendus de l'autre
côté du pont là où les troupes russes
ont pris position pendant trois jours
dans les quartiers nous avons discuté
avec les habitants qui raconte bien
comment les soldats russes sont venus
chez eux dans leur maison les combats
ont duré trois jours et les soldats
russes et bien sont entrés dans les
maisons voient encore leurs rations
militaires les les chenilles des tanks
sont encore visibles dans les rues et
les soldats russes ont volé un peu tout
ce qui leur étaient utiles dans les
maisons c'est ce que nous ont raconté
les habitants du quartier à la fois est
des vêtements de la nourriture des
outils mécaniques les les forces
chrétiennes et la défense sans
territoriales c'est à dire les habitants
de la ville qui ont pris les armes pour
la défendre ont réussi à repousser ses
troupes russes les combats ont été durs
ils ont duré trois jours et si trois
jours de combats sans eau sans
électricité avec la majeure partie des
habitants aux abris nous avons discuté
avec une personne chez qui les russes se
sont installés un monsieur de 80 ans qui
nous disait moi je n'aurais pas adressé
la parole parce que je n'ai rien à dire
à l'occupant c'est un peu l'état
d'esprit si alors les russes ont été
repoussés de cette ville de bosnie
sienne ce qui met les habitants savent
qu'ils y reviendront probablement c'est
ce que nous a également dit le maire de
la ville pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce que cette ville est située sur
l'axé entre la grande ville portuaire de
dessins et pièces parce que elle
permettrait si les russes veulent
contourner nicolas yves et bien
d'encercler odessa et la troisième et
dernière raison c'est qu'il y à une
centrale nucléaire juste à côté de la
ville qui approvisionne la région et au
delà en électricité ce qui en fait
évidemment une cible stratégique
importante pour les troupes russes